[Music]
well george
the bear is in the house uh oh
i keep seeing the headlines the bear is
here the bear has arrived
the bear market so scary scary bear
now bulls are scary too but for some
reason there's something about the bear
market dave it's got people riled up
what's going on there well
a bear market is like a recession it's a
thing that the media throws around is
like wow
tornado is coming get your bathtub put
on a helmet they got my click yeah
the bear marker's a bear market oh it's
a recession
oh
these are these are not good things well
we do have we have a tendency to
hyperbole and overreact and create
headlines and
get people to watch our new shows by
doing these things what are my chances
of living just hit me straight on book
to talk about the bear market on fox a
little bit later and
so
um just you know i always get the phone
call when things are bad and so um
here we go again so here's a bear market
market's down 20 percent
that's definition that's it that's it i
thought the sky was falling nope chicken
little not happening
uh kind of disappointing i thought that
would be more but you know if you were
buying shoes and they were on sale 20
off you'd be excited i love i love a
good sale you know if you're buying a
car and it was 20 off that'd be a nice
thing but when your stocks are 20 off
and you get to buy them at a discount
um people don't think that way they
think that they've i've lost all my
money in the stock market
no you haven't lost anything unless you
sold it
i don't even know how much i've lost
because i haven't lost anything because
i haven't sold it
the only person that gets hurt on a
roller coaster are those that jump off
in the middle of the ride
ride the coaster baby if you're staring
maybe right at the 401k balance you're
saying don't freak out i'm saying quit
staring at your 401k balance i even
looked at mine don't cash it out well
you're just yeah now here's the deal you
are not in this
for a two-week play
your 401k is not a two-week play it's
not a two-month play it's not a two-year
play your 401k is a 20 to or a 40 year
play
and so all you should care about is
where the market's going to be when you
get there that's all you should care
about
you don't have to care about what it is
in a given moment and the reason you
don't have to care about that is you're
thinking do you think that 20 off
honestly people if you're one of those
that's freaking out right now if you're
the one i'm making fun of because you're
melting down and you're in drama queen
mode if that's you
ask yourself do you really think that
the american economy is going to implode
now i mean stop your little feelings i'm
talking about use your intellect
breathe
do you really think
that all of these companies coca-cola
mcdonald's
home depot
apple
are gonna become worth zero
now come on
breathe
breathe with me
they're not
okay why are they down
because we have a screwed up economy
because of covid and joe biden screwing
with the gas pipelines
it's pretty simple
kovit's gonna go away and hopefully joe
will after a few more years
and it's gonna be okay right
quit screwing with stuff in the economy
and let the economy run and it runs just
fine
but covid messed up supply chain supply
demand prices went all wonky i mean my
god it's like the mississippi ran
backwards used cars went up in value
what a weird world we live in i mean
seriously
this is a weird economy and people who
used to get ten dollars an hour to put
bread on the shelves now get thirty
dollars an hour to put bread on the
shelves and we wonder why the price of
bread went up because we all want a
universal wage for doing nothing
and so socialism is kicking in and you
guys are loving the benefits of it
and so this this is what's going on so
the bear market is simply the stock
market is following us into a recession
the stock peop the people are investors
are not feeling happy
they're feeling sad
and so they're not willing to pay as
much for a single stock as they were
thus the price of stock the stock market
is going down and it's down 20 percent
which is a lot but it is not time to
panic
and if i were here's the thing
what is it buffett says he says uh i try
to be greedy when others are fearful are
fearful and fearful when others are
greedy great quote
and uh now you know i don't know if
buffett is actually greedy i don't look
at him as that type of person like
greedy but like more like yeah i want to
i want to be this is the time to buy
that's contrarian mentality in other
words
contrary to the typical person out there
the typical investor okay so if the
investors are running away from the
stock market and it's going down that
means it's on sale when i was a kid and
we went to kmart which is now gone
that's how long ago this was but the
dinosaurs roamed the earth back then if
you went into kmart they had this little
box they would roll around that had a
little pole on it on top of it was a
blue light
like a like a like a
policeman's light right
like uh sheriff taylor is in town barney
fife is here right and so they would
flip that little light on and move it
over next to something and take whatever
it was on that rack and put it on sale
it's called a blue light special
and so you're on it's on sale and we
would all us rednecks would run to kmart
and go to the blue light specials and
get deals on whatever it was that we
didn't need at kmart and so but that's
all the stock market is it's on sale
it's a blue light special right now it's
down 20
you have the opportunity to buy so if
you think that the stock market if you
think the american economy companies
like home depot apple
and so on are going to be worth as a
group more 20 years from today then you
would be happy to buy more shares right
now while they're on sale would you not
that is
logical but not if you watch the news oh
my god you know it's just crazy out
there right
and so sitting about to put the helmet
on the tornado is coming it's oh my god
like a bike helmet is going to help you
in a tornado you idiot but now
what about the group of people who are
actually trying to retire right now or
they're recently retired you don't use
all your money you don't like okay today
is my retirement day i'm taking all of
that money cash out eight hundred
thousand dollars and i'm gonna put it on
my kitchen table that is not what people
do at retirement okay what do you do at
retirement if you have eight hundred
thousand dollars in mutual funds do you
take it all out no
well you do
you take an income off of it
and you say i want that eight hundred
thousand to give me eighty thousand
dollars a year
and so you take eighty thousand dollars
a year off well it didn't make eighty
thousand so you use up a little your 800
and next year when you take out 80 and
it goes up 200 then you have to worry
about it because it all goes back
and so just set up your income out of it
you didn't lose your retirement
calm your butt
down
we are going into a little lightweight
recession two quarters in a row of the
economy not growing a recession is the
gross domestic product the adding up of
all goods and services in america two
quarters in a row shrunk that is a
recession it receded like my hairline
okay i wasn't gonna say it that's how it
works you weren't gonna say it but i did